hello and welcome to GameSpot's review
of Rage 2 my name is Jake and I'm here
with Michael Michael you reviewed rage 2
you gave it a 6 which is fair give me
the rundown of your view what do you
think first things first is that combat
is dope now that's like the main
attraction of this game and I say that
my reviews like the superpowers the
weapons they all feel great the problem
is that everything feels so short
whether it's the main mission or if it's
the side quest everything just ends so
abruptly and I think also another thing
worth mentioning is that the world
building and kind of the storylines are
not that great I'm not asking a game to
have a groundbreaking story but give me
a reason to be there and that's another
aspect in which it's underwhelming but
again like I said the combats pretty
sweet well why don't we start with that
then what makes the combat enrage to so
great so the superpower is called nano
Trites
are these abilities you have to take
down your foes in a very gruesome manner
to be honest there's like this my
favorite one is a slam which is a ground
pound
and you can upgrade it to a point where
you as soon as you go up in the air you
create this black hole where enemies
just kind of get sucked into the center
force of it and then as soon as you
smash down you can splatter like ten
fools at one [ __ ] mess
yeah and it's super effective to be
honest especially when you're fighting
like a bunch of mutants or bandits all
at the same time it's very effective it
also just feels really good to use and
also the shatter ability which is
effective for taking out armored
opponents but also just like sending
fools flying against the wall or out
over a cliff all that stuff just is so
much fun to use and also the weapons
like I mentioned you get the standard
stuff like a salt rifle shotgun and
rocket launcher but the grav dart gun is
really cool you just shoot a full a
bunch with a needle like almost like a
needle or yeah you like paint targets
and then you fire another round where
they're gonna go and they'll fly yeah it
looks really funny but it's also it's
also effective on armored enemies so
there's there's use cases for all this
stuff as wacky as it may seem
there's also overdrive to which almost
puts a twist on your guns too that you
have right yeah yeah so you go to
overdrive once you accumulated enough
kills and then it gives you an alternate
fire mode for all your weapons and makes
them even more powerful and overdrive is
super effective because it starts giving
you more health as well so you go into
this mode where you're almost invincible
and you're just like mowing fools down
and that's great and with the
superpowers Nano traits in mind and also
the weapons that you have you can kind
of create this momentum where you're
cycling through all of your abilities as
you're going through all these rooms and
tearing down your enemies it's it's just
a ton of fun to do
[Music]
[Applause]
unfortunately in your view you also
mention that the game doesn't really do
a lot to keep up that rhythm once you
get into a flow it pulls you out pretty
quickly like you'll finish the mission
what do you mean by that why don't you
explain that yeah I'll start by talking
about how the main missions are
structured because there's a car there's
a couple main missions and then
everything just kind of ends before I
kind of get my fill and it never none of
the main missions really build up to
something
or very few times does it build up to
something like I mentioned the mission
where you go through this lab and then
eventually fight like a big monster in a
courtyard like that's cool but that's
like one of the only situations in which
the the mission actually funnels you
through a bunch of combat scenarios
everything just kind of like ends with a
I don't know not a bang that's for damn
sure
with a pop-up telling you dive into that
later but yeah another it never
surprises you it never gives you like a
distinct challenge at the end or never
like you know like I said it never
builds up to something because you just
kind of go through a couple rooms with
some enemies but it's all over before
you can get your fill and that also
extends to the the main quest overall
too because you can I spent like 12
hours to finish this game but that's
doing a bunch of the side cause you
could probably knock this main mission
out in eight hours maybe I bet people
could do it less too if they were really
trying yeah it's so short and not only
are the missions underwhelming but just
the overall structure of the campaign is
underwhelming as well and that extends
to the side quests because yeah you get
a map full of these different activities
do like clearing out a bandit camp or a
clean-out roadblock or going to a mutant
nests like those lasts for maybe like
two minutes tops
and again you're cut short before you
can build that satisfying momentum that
you're capable of with all these weapons
and abilities so yeah you might look
like there's a lot to do but you know I
get the gyrocopter I fly to one side
quest and then I finish that in like a
minute then I fly to the next one and
finish that
and it never feels like things are
connected it never feels like I'm
challenged or surprised in the side
quests as well there's a couple other
things you can do like convoys which is
like some car combat type stuff in out
in the open world there's the MPTV stuff
and there's racing but that doesn't
uplift the game in the sense and it
doesn't make use of the best parts of
this game and that's the problem is that
the game never sets up the stage for you
to do the cool things that you want to
do
there are moments but it just doesn't
it's there's not enough of it hey Willie
I'm eyeballing one sketchy looking place
[Music]
so another thing that was interesting
interviews you talked about how a lot of
the missions don't really do anything
with the open world a lot of the
missions are very focused in one area
it's never like get to point A and point
B while people do chasing after you or
you need to hunt down someone who's on
the run or something like that it's
always just go to this area fight these
enemies and and then report back to
whoever you did that mission or that's
it's disappointing because you have this
vast open world that looks pretty cool
to be averse to like it's a pretty
diverse post-apocalyptic world yeah you
have those desert plains in the south
and they have that jungle to the north
and it looks nice it's just like there's
one main mission that takes you to the
jungle area there's one main mission
that takes you to the desert area and
they all take place in imports and it's
disappointing because like you built
this awesome open world but you don't
use any of it and I think about games
like GTA and how they use their open
world for their mission structure
whereas rage 2 is just a reason to go
from point A to point B and once I go
through these missions its corridors and
or just like this secluded area which
would be fine if those missions actually
you know lasted long or gave me a
challenge or presents it new things to
me but it doesn't make up for it in that
regard and now that I mention it I also
think about games like doom and
Wolfenstein other Bethesda shooters
where those games are just like non-stop
action they make good use of their time
now you might think like oh this game is
like maybe 12 hours to beat and so is
doom and Wolfenstein but there's so much
non action in rage 2 that it doesn't
justify you know that amount of time
really
that's jerseys armored Jersey they
killed him
you're brave enough to put on his Armour
brave enough to do his job why don't we
move on to world building in the story
which is something also you felt was
kind of lacking yeah for a
post-apocalyptic world you kind of
expect this game to be wild and crazy
and off-the-wall and all that that's how
they marketed it - yeah that's another
thing - it's like all the build ups of
this game is like it's gonna have
attitude it's gonna be badass and it's
gonna be deranged but you kind of get
that sense in the first 20 minutes of
the game where they introduce these
characters who you think are supposed to
be important and then they just kill
them off and I'm like yeah okay like
you're gonna surprise me by you know
subverting my expectations or whatever
and not caring about like traditional
story beats but the problem is like
after that it just it doesn't go
anywhere it doesn't build on that
attitude there is actually no attitude
in this game I was expecting more of
that but I just couldn't find it in
every attempt that they did to have sort
of charisma or personality was just lame
like I talked about the that dude what's
his name Clayton was supposed to be this
douchebag or whatever and you're
supposed to hate him but he just comes
off as annoying
this is the multi watt nerve center of
the plague empire my office the cockpit
from which I control my vast financial
like make me hate that character he's a
villain and he's supposed to be like a
like a piece of [ __ ] make me believe
that he is or give me a reason to hate
him it's just kind of like lame and they
have like these dumb weird dialogue
sequences that it just that it doesn't
do anything and I'm not asking rage to
have a groundbreaking story like I said
earlier I just want to have a world that
kind of has reasons to either care about
these things or string all of these
events together in some sort of coherent
way is there anything else you want to
add that you may have not been able to
touch on in your review or just other
things you think people should know
about rage - I won't talk about those
pop-up notifications man
so every time you finish a sidequest you
get a game pausing notifications as a
you got 300 bucks
hey you also built up this this loyalty
meter with a certain person I don't know
that's just annoying because for a game
this supposed to be fast paced and just
like keeps going going going for a home
progress bar or notification for
resources that you earned like just
pausing the entire game like yeah it
does the same it's tutorials - yeah it's
constantly searching you third or fourth
of the game was just like press a to
jump yep I know yeah and that's another
way this game kind of breaks momentum
but also like the I don't really like I
said I don't really care about the story
or anything like that but I always want
to listen to the dialogue sequences and
even those pop ups just like happen
while I'm in the middle of listening to
a conversation so yeah there's just a
lot of small odd design choices Ranger a
long time and there you have it that's
why GameSpot gave Rage 2 a 6 out of 10
thank you for stopping by and we'll see
you next time
[Music]
you